what is up there reject nation we gonna
watch the next episode of brooklyn
nine-nine today full-length watch as
long as we sync up with the time girl
for b9 or over at our patreon page thank
you to all become super jacks for
checking all the stuff we've got offer
over there if you can't share support
over our patreon please leave a like
that would show your support over here
by doing that and a comment perhaps also
uh thanks to the boys of prep for
helping us setting down these highlights
let's get into action pipes
[Music]
okay squad the funeral is at three
o'clock i want you all on your best
behavior yeah and all eyes are gonna be
on us because freaking frack here killed
captain dozerman hey we accidentally
startled a man with a genetic heart
condition if you really think about it
his parents killed him
he is the worst captain we've ever had
he drew boobies on my bulletproof vest
he stared at me for 90 seconds while he
ate an entire peach he heard that i
speak spanish and he made me fire his
housekeeper
jake is going to
befriend the vulture so he lays off of
us it's true i'm gonna bro down with him
now somebody give me a pukashel necklace
i'm going full douche
[Music]
never go full douche we got off on the
wrong foot here and i believe
it's cause we're just too damn similar
you do absolutely we both love premium
tequila man robin thicke oh yeah gots to
have my poops that's two gods too you
also like okinawan martial arts because
you left this in my back what i'm saying
einstein is that you stabbed me in my
back how so ah we came up with a plan
jake is going to befriend the vulture so
he lays off of us oh [ __ ]
i want you to dump santiago and that's
an order what you can't do that it's
completely against the rules okay sonia
sotomayor
but what i could do for totally
unrelated reasons
is have you busted back down to a beat
cop i can learn to love nip slip no you
either love them or you don't it's too
late you dumped santiago or you kissed
that detective badge goodbye god damn it
what an [ __ ] a man is dead i would
hate it if these doors opened and
everyone stopped working to applaud us
huh
nothing
you must be loving this
yes
captain holt is here today he loves us
and he's got tons of sway in the
department he'll tell the vulture to
back down yeah he'll be all vulture i
must insist that you
desist
you ever want to bust out that whole
impression at home
i'd be okay with that kinky
duly noted super disturbing but i'm
definitely gonna do it
nice g-spot rosa charles oh i missed you
guys cheese
charles you gotta have something weird
and tragic going on not unless you call
hooking up with a girl at a funeral
weird and tragic we were seated next to
each other two funerals ago last funeral
we made out in parking lot this time
something naughty this way comes
nice by the pricking of my thumbs
charles boyle is going to that funeral
and he's going to put the bone back in
boneyard nice work charles i got a
fridge for my protein shakes i got a
kettlebell station i got a wolf that i
killed in utah wow i'm fairly certain
that's a dog yeah it was dark
you're a desk jockey this is my precinct
now and the sooner that you accept that
the better i know my way out cause you
used to work here i keep
forgetting everybody does
what a dick fighting words
it's great to see you back at the 99 sir
yes
there it is that classic jake holt
banter zinger's just flying around
well i know how much you love hot gas so
you probably heard amy and i have been
dating and we would love your approval
no
oh
yeah
all right tell me if i don't dump amy
he's gonna demote me you gotta help us
let me stop you right there peralta i'm
just some guy in pr but we thought i
can't save your ass i don't work here
anymore and the sooner you accept that
the better no
never no i know captain dozerman was a
nightmare and that none of us liked him
but i'm gonna need all of you to pretend
like you're sad everyone make a sad face
scully you are nailing it my wife just
texted she's leaving me good use it
[Laughter]
here for you scully i gotta go find him
now be respectful and grieve your asses
off i don't know why this is happening
scully i love it everyone follow his
lead
[Laughter]
it's davis garmin chief of detectives
holt said he could overrule the vulture
exactly the only question now is will he
believe us yes because we're gonna take
a page from the vultures book the big
book of small butts what
we're gonna secretly record the vulture
telling you to dump me then we'll play
it for chief garmin then we're gonna
totally have sex on top of each other
you get to keep your job yes that oh
charles your jump off is here hello
detective
nicely done i like the way your butt
looks today i've been doing lunges in
the shower well this got upsetting real
quick i want to live in this moment
forever i got us a hotel room across the
street yes you did i'll meet you all
right
m-e-a-t
charles it is not like you to have sex
with a total stranger really tell that
to me in an hour when we've had sex 23
times
that's a lot of sex oh whoa
slow down sir you always sniff the
bouquet maybe the old hole did but the
new holt chugs beaujolais from a
burgundy glass without a gear oh it's a
sarturne glass the alcohol has rendered
me a simpleton
i'm gonna use that they're gonna have
one drink with me sergeant all right for
old time take one drink and then we go
one drink
a good drink what is going
good for you terry good for you hey
captain i was looking for you inside
one thing i won't do is fart in church
this is god's house
that's a good flicker you said to me
that i have to dump santiago or else
you're gonna bust me down to beat cop
what i remember jake is you pretend to
be my bro and me being like i'm on to
you dilweed
oh no
look we just need a couple of minutes to
chat that's it i'm not gonna stop
playing until you blow it all right just
keep it to me yeah all right let's do
this your ex-boyfriend is pathetic you
should be glad that i ordered him to
dump you
swish
kobe
please tell me you got that yes
yes you're amazing
[Music]
that was we are the champions was it
wasn't that dozerman and i were pretty
much besties went on an annual fishing
trip together cayuga lake caught a lot
of co-hosts salmon we are both so bummed
that he's dead super bummed yeah right
on
right on
morning floral arrangement up front with
a picture of dozerman and 30 of his
friends holding a big fish okay yooka
lake i pulled straight from the guest
book and coho salmon that's just
something i know about for being a man
of the world our special today is coho
salmon sounds disgusting do you have
chicken fingers
[Laughter]
you went on those trips i did indeed
pretty much single-handedly organized
those things myself so you were the one
who brought all the prostitutes
uh
no
how about if you tell me things about
yourself and then i tell you how little
i care about them okay
i'm an only child not interested i was
born in delaware who even asked you i
like that i don't care what you like i
guess it works tell me one more thing
she's a vegan
what is going on you're right i couldn't
help myself
oh oh buddy no laugh it up can i wait
till after the funeral
shh sir my life stinks sharon's on bed
rest my favorite mango yogurt got
discontinued
[Laughter]
when i saw you
in the office this morning i wanted to
give you the biggest hug but the vulture
told you not to i hate going to work and
you're not there
everything is garbage
everything is garbage i should put that
in my message of hope
that's a really good idea
i'm not the coho king my name is jake
and your husband was only my captain for
like a day are you the jake that killed
him oh god no i'm prostitute jake i love
prostitutes you need to go you should
leave right now you need to leave right
now it's a poor woman
oh no wait i just
need to play one quick recording of my
boss
no
that's not cool jake well we were just
taking a page out of your book yeah what
do you do next huh you can start wearing
leather bracelets
good luck pulling off that chunky b with
those skinny little girl wrists of yours
you're a beat cop again
i just crushed your dreams okay i know
things seem really bad right now but we
just need a minute to think
[Music]
i'm not gonna let you throw away your
dream job amy this is good this is a
six-day relationship we don't know what
it is
and now for a message of hope ah a
message of hope right on time everything
is garbage
your colleague
your dream job
your mango yogurt
our relationship was only six days
but that's not nothing
it was long enough for me to know that
we had something special and sure there
may be obstacles him having passed away
for example
i just
care about being with you
captain dozerman
an adult man
move over peralta
move
open mic
it'll be focused primarily on the mango
yolk
don't move me i lost something important
too shoo
shoo not a big fan of my speech huh no i
loved it
i mean i wish it hadn't been not awake
and i wish you hadn't kept referring to
me as your dead boss yeah pretty much
suck butt but still was somehow the best
of the three toasts
i'm all out of plans i have one
pole saves your ass captain that was
moved by your speech peralta the syntax
was problematic plus nice and your
vocabulary is a true indictment of the
public school system
i love the nine-nine and i'm not gonna
turn my back on the squad so i fixed
your problem with the vulture really i
may just be a guy in pr but what does
the vulture love more than anything
nip slips publicity captain pembroke how
would you like your face on the nypd
website
really
yes
yes
culture will not bust you down or stand
in the way of you two dating sir i don't
know how to thank you anything
for the nine-nine did i died he totally
approves of us
i missed out that impression but which
of those relationships made you happiest
before it ended
my marriage
vivian yeah because you connect with
them emotionally something we did not do
because i'm a higher level of being like
her from the movie her hmm mm-hmm good
movie you think i should look for
someone i can have emotional intercourse
with uh i wish i hadn't said it like
that but yeah no time to lose put on
your sunglasses and to see if there's
anything in my teeth
charles boyle you ready for love bang
the widow never worn these again
i think you should have banged the widow
grieving widow
bullseye
funeral crashers
show off john i really feel for terry
this episode as somebody who recently
had oral surgery i've been eating a lot
of yogurt there's a lot of varieties of
yogurt and not all yogurts are created
equal and if i found that exact right
yogurt and then they discontinued it
for the few short weeks in which i
should stick to
cool and
you know soft foods i would be crushed
i'd really would so i think terry's was
the most emotionally resonant story in
here no one took him seriously you know
no one takes the little things seriously
in this day and age it's always ah this
guy is dead or ah we want true love man
yogurt is always there all right it's
there longer than people it's there
longer than love
it's the one true reliable thing in this
universe and i was quite moved by uh by
terry this episode
do you think gee
i'd echo everything you said
i think that yogurt is the great
foundation of los angeles i remember
when we first started getting
um
well it's not yogurtland for the
yogurtland cheese no not before
menchie's was the other one
there's yogurtland there's yogurtland
what's the word
uh
oh yes i can see it and i cannot figure
out what the name is it's like the first
one and then menchie's popped up and
then there was yogurt is it a zone
i don't know this is like a froyo zone
or something like that
we were done trying to figure it out uh
yeah when that
popped up and then i saw how frozen
yogurt became the new wave beyond ice
cream gave me hope you know especially
when you hunt and self-serve
oh dude you can just go ham on the
toppings on the flavors whatever you can
fit into the cup and then pandemic
happened and then you couldn't do it
yourself anymore you had to wait in line
like a freak and then
would let some other person some
i'm supposed to just trust this stranger
with my cup to give me the exact amount
of serving that i desire but a crock of
[ __ ]
i was like it's like being in a
relationship you can't touch the person
and that's what it was like with the
yogurt so i feel like yogurt's been
rough for me in a lot of ways so
absolutely i do think what terry's going
through is a really rough experience
definitely and this just made me feel
really guilty because i remember when
john wanted to date someone
i told him no
you can't do it not around here it's
affecting your work
and if you continue dating this person
you're no longer part of the channel man
that's right plain and simple
and this just showed me that you should
have gone out with her oh bummer you had
a chance hey you know whatever man roxy
striker could have been yours who needs
roxy's dryer
and who needs uh you know intimate
companionship and affection you know
well she was in a serious relationship
at the time i don't care inappropriately
i thought it was guys we're having this
america
what it wants
this would have really happened yes it
did um
facts
[Music]
and truths yes and full truths yeah so
that made me feel pretty bad and then
you know boyle having emotionless sex
yeah
oh this guy we're good
this guy
wow
tons
tons
compounding amounts
i'm talking like
sandbags upon sandbags level
of
unemotional intimacy
man i have
like i i can't even cross into the west
side of california anymore
without getting into an awkward
conversation with a woman
or a guy for that matter i cannot tell
you just like whoa i'm pretty sure i'm
not like it's i just slain i got
diseases through the roof dude you
smashing so they are they i cannot
relate with boyle at all in this
situation i had to learn what it was
like to have
emotional intimacy because of the amount
of
just
like is like the allegory that comes to
mind it's like a kid at a batting cage
you know just knocking them all
man
wow
yes swinging anything that comes past
your face you know i was just
right i was i was what you call
a baby chick magnet man yeah
[Music]
that's right hen's popping up left and
right
give me that baby chick baby baby chick
magnet man yeah yeah yeah uh-huh i was i
was part of the earth's gravitational
pull
for for
the women
yeah and uh this guy though constantly
emotional about it he can't stop that's
what happened wrong with him rocks chew
him up like roxy just get to know me
just just just peer into my soul and
validate my intimate life my emotional
life is too bad man so she just wouldn't
do it
but i get it man boyle
it's just funny how he ah that's funny
sincere thought i get it now
she's he said
meet m-e-a-t which was a reference
to what greg would tell all the men and
women of the greater santa monica area
about his junk
and now he said meet and then finds out
she's a
vegan so she wouldn't want it anyway
damn that's terrible it's a bummer no
sausage today
but
you feel like you know if you're giving
her your meat package then it's going
against her you know
moral choice in life of
what to ingest so i don't know i think
it's pretty dirty well and plus two i
mean if it's if she hasn't had meat in a
long long long long time her body might
just reject it make you sick so it's
better that they don't do it that's true
that's a really good point actually you
can habituate to that lifestyle and then
all of a sudden even just the littlest
tap just
i remember all the vegans i did with in
wiho
that's west hollywood by the way it's
slang that's what we would call them i
said weho because i'm a man [ __ ]
that's also what you refer to you know
you when you're out with your other
fellow [ __ ]
yeah that's great yeah so much women and
men
um
lost count
so yeah i i i would go to weho and then
you know that's there's a lot of
vegetarian vegans out there and and they
were just
like so
sick and repulsed by the time
we even started but they couldn't resist
they couldn't resist they're like even
though i know it's it's it that the
allegory that comes to mind is like my
relationship with amc's popcorn
i i always get a large bucket
and the refill i get the refills ahead
of time because i don't want to miss a
second
and i get sick
every time i feel like i drank a gallon
of motor oil but then i still go back
for more always and that's what my hoes
the wee hoes
we host would say because i had a lot of
emotional sex a lot of people did i
mentioned that i mentioned that it was a
lot dude
you're just like those retreats you are
the the the co whatever that salmon is
king
dude i know king i know exactly the
reference you are pulling yeah i i can
yes and this all day yeah and i i will
definitely once his camera stops rolling
because
all the prostitutes you invited on our
fishing trips yeah
oh oh you're talking about what happened
in the show that's that's that's from
the show but it's also actually cold
stuff something that
oh probably that's small probably what
they took inspiration from for this you
know as like an ironic nod to real life
like oh this cult activity but oh look
the old chief was into that you know
scandal
so
what have we learned today
john was in a serious relationship with
a popular influencer that's right and
yeah you can't hold this guy down nope
everyone's had a piece why haven't you
it's at the point that if we haven't
done something
i'm surprised something's wrong with you
i'm like whoa
what
you haven't done let me make it up to
you
let's make it last time casual
conversation every day of the week
i'm totally polly
no yeah you you are i don't understand
your lifestyle it's crazy and way too
out of the box way too unorthodox
you know you make a war
um
because that's me that's my character
that's why he's smashing 24 7. no seals
can't
can't stop the greg train he's chew
chewing through town choo choo choo with
the bagpipe and all do you hear that
well what's paul revere doing coming
through to town
greg's coming
greg's coming
and he's playing pony on the back with
pipes what's going on and what's going
on here did you turn on fox news they're
preaching some type of false propaganda
that the ladies no longer want greg well
that's
fake news that is fake fake news fox
news that take news tucker dale or
whatever his name is hucker carls
carlson doesn't know what he's talking
about
carson daly's wrong man that's right man
what does he know so you know he's going
on the fox news and carson daly don't
shut up man
what does ben shapiro know about greg
alba i don't know what a ben shapiro is
that the star wars guy it's the star
wars guy yeah who directed all the cold
wars yeah all right guys well i think we
have learned a valuable lesson today
always be honest
always be closing
that's
that's what that's what i say i would
hit the town
with hottie most desired actor today
alec baldwin
would just go around the whiteboard
always be closing
yeah
yeah man those in there
closing the the deal with the
the house
i've never had an intercourse once in my
life i'm sorry for lying to you guys oh
it's okay
i tried it once it hurt
quite a bit it always does
well that's good emotionally and
physically you should just avoid it
physically it left me permanently
damaged
[Music]
that's the price
you pay for addiction
to
friction let's do a patron of the day
shout out
everett pixel my baker matt if you wanna
know someone who's constantly just
getting
all the ladies it's everett pixelmite
baker you know why because he is the one
he's pixel knight
he invented
the trillion dollar industry that you
can access for free worldwide
do i need to say what it is i think you
guys know what i'm talking about
because
dude i'm always watching it constantly
like non-stop definitely um yeah and and
with that he's just met so many honeys
or guys i don't know what is which way
he swings but no matter what he is
just like everything i've ever learned
if you're like where i got you guys so
good at getting all these people
everett pixel my baker taught tommy the
ways he's my mentor i'm the mentee and
we would go around hey tommy and alec
baldwin how to close chicks man and so
everett picks on my baker he does it all
dude he created the porn industry and on
top of that too he bakes for the ladies
after it's done it's called
cupcake on top man
two girls one cupcake is the special
video that he made so every pixel mike
baker thanks so much for being part of
our patreon and showing your support if
you skipped ahead to your shout out
instead of watching this whole video and
the review
then you're gonna be wildly confused why
this is your shout out and you're
probably gonna pledge for the patreon
which i totally get man just send me a
message first i'll clarify everything
for you just give me time to apologize
all right guys we'll see you soon
and uh keep a lookout for every picture
of my baker's book um you know how
how to uh how to pick up
the art of being a pickup artist the art
of the art of the art of the art of the
art the art of of picking up artists
how to pick up a pick-up artist pick up
the art of the pick-up pick up the
pick-up artist
something that
no one's ever been able to figure out me
and i could tell when someone's playing
the game
because i'm
i'm paulie
[Music]